[Music]
ursula k le guin's third earth scene
novel the farthest shore is in part the
story of a crisis and its resolution and
you might say well every story is like
that but this is especially so it begins
with a crisis for earth sea itself at
the isle of roke the place where the
high arts of magic are taught and
furthered and understood
and it really in a way at the pinnacle
of their power the ring of aerith akba
has been brought back they've got a
great arc mage in gab they've got you
know a wonderful council of masters at
rogue things seems to be going along
quite swimmingly and one of the problems
with crises is that very often
there isn't recognition at the start
that there is a genuine crisis and
people disagree about that and then
acting on incomplete information they
come to
different interpretations judgments
resolutions and that is exactly what we
see happening so what is the crisis in
very blunt terms you can say it's a
crisis of magic magic is failing
and so is knowledge and magic and
knowledge are closely connected together
along with that as we're going to see
it's not just a matter of what people
know how to do
it's also
a
lack of
you could say direction
a listlessness a sort of affective
problem as well and we'll see this
particularly
in some of the towns that ged is going
to venture to with aaron first we have
aaron of enlarge coming and saying that
i've got some news and he says you know
my lord that the prince my father is a
wizardly man being of the lineage of
morad having spent a year here on roke
in his youth some power he has and
knowledge though he seldom uses his arts
being concerned with the ruling and
ordering of his realm the governance of
cities and trade
and so he goes down and he says
there was a tale that came to my
father's ears and he had the man sent
for to tell it the sea captain said that
on the isle
of
narvaduen which is some 500 miles west
of us there was no more magic
spells had no power there he said the
words of wizardry were forgotten
my father asked him if it was that all
the sorcerers and witches had left the
aisle and he answered there were some
there who had been sorcerers but they
cast no more spells and my father said
were not the folk of narvaduin dismayed
and the sea captain said no they seemed
uncaring indeed there was sickness among
them and their autumn harvest had been
poor and they still seemed careless they
were like sick men like a man who's been
told he must die within the year and
tells himself it is not true and that he
will live forever they go about without
looking at the world
when other traitors returned they
repeated the tale that narva duane had
become a poor land and lost the arts of
wizardry
and so this is a story that's being told
and notice that there's a connection
between knowledge and
not and wizardry and feeling
and
being prosperous doing well living a
good life they are becoming poor they
are living a life that's mere living and
then something else happens in the story
he says in the new year in the festival
of the lambs
my father named the wizard root to say
the spells of increase over the lands
but root came back to our hall
distressed and laid his staff down and
say said my lord i cannot say the spells
my father questioned him but he could
only say i have forgotten the words and
the patterning so my father went to the
marketplace and said the spells himself
and the festival was completed
and he said to me i said
i said the words but i do not know if
they had
meaning
so he says my father believes this
matter in the tale of narva do and show
some evil at work in our part of the
world he desires the counsel of the wise
now notice what's happening he
the the the prince is sending his son to
get information from the wizards that
wrote what he's really doing
is providing the wizards at rogue some
information that they need because
they're also getting similar stories
coming from some other places far off
not near roke not near the center of
earth sea and there's actually a
suggestion at one point that perhaps
they lack perspective in rock because
they're too well protected
by
the magic the things that can hold evils
back and perhaps also because they have
the imminent grove whose roots reach
down to the bottom of the world itself
so
what's going on out in the boonies we
could say out in the archipelago in the
reaches
and then what's happening in the closer
islands and then what's happening at
rock these are different
matters at least at first as we're going
to see
so
ged has a few meetings first he
talks well first he talks with the
doorman and he says i'm going to talk
with the master namer and i'm going to
talk with the patterner and the doorman
is kind of an enigmatic figure who who
doesn't say much just smiles a lot
but he goes get to meet with the master
patterner in the imminent grove
and in the discussion that they have
he says
there's word from
uh narvaduen and enlar the same south
and southwest north and northwest of the
patterner never looking from the round
web and he said we shall come here this
evening this is the best place for
council and then the patterner says i
don't have any counsel
you look to me for that sort of thing
but i don't have any counsel why not
i am afraid
there is fear at the roots
the imminent grove the trees who speak
in some way communicate with human
beings they are afraid this is something
that's quite big something dangerous god
says we must look to the dark springs
we've enjoyed the sunlight too long
basking in that peace which the healing
of the ring brought accomplishing small
things fishing the shallows
tonight we must question the depths and
so they have their meeting and we find
out about what happened at that meeting
a little bit later the tale is really
told in large part through aaron's eyes
with a few
digressions like that
and so
the next thing that we see is the seven
masters because the namer is going to
stay in his tower the patterner and the
imminent grove the seven other masters
of rock are having breakfast with the
archmage get and with this young man
aaron and they hear his his news from
him
and um
then they they discuss what's going to
to happen
um
he says this is the door keeper or
actually this
this is a gad saying these are the
masters of rock are in seven of the
nine
all of them know your errand here my
lords this is the son of morad and
notice what this is a really great line
here
no pride roused an aaron at that phrase
but only a kind of dread he was proud of
his lineage but thought of himself only
as the ear of princes of one of the
house of enlarge morad from whom that
house descended had been dead two
thousand years his deeds were matters of
legends not of this present world
he did not dare look up at the faces of
the eight mages and the art mage says
come let us breakfast together and
they they talk about what's going on and
they have a little bit of chit chat and
then they recount what happened at the
knights meeting
in the imminent grove
and they discuss
what their positions are they didn't
reach any sort of resolution
why not was it that they couldn't
achieve consensus
yes but the reason was
they didn't find a clear pattern of what
was going on in order to know how to
respond to a crisis
you have to have some sort of sense of
what is actually
happening so you can decide whether
you're going to intervene or not
and they can't yet tell
what is happening and there's a you
could say an alignment with the master
herbal wind key the changer and the
summoner all saying listen i don't think
this is that big of a deal
here's here's what they say
the master herbal says that we resolve
nothing is itself a judgment and the
grove are patterns found but we found
nothing there but argument so he's
taking kind of a neutral stance
and the master changer says only because
we could not see the pattern playing we
do not know enough
rumors from wathort news from enlad
strange news and should be looked to but
to raise such a great fear and a little
foundation is unneedful
our power is not threatened only because
a few sorcerers have forgotten their
spells notice that this is the guy who's
from the very island that aaron is from
where magic is failing and he's saying
ah it doesn't sound like that big of a
deal right so that's a bit of a stronger
statement
and the master wind key says so say i
have we not all our powers do not the
trees of the grove grow and put forth
leaves do not the storms of heaven obey
our word who can fear for the art of
wizardry which is the oldest of the arts
of man saying
again don't worry about it this is you
know an ancient art we're going to be
just fine and then finally the master
summoner says
no man no power can bind the action of
wizardry or steal the words of power for
they are the very words of the making
one who could silence them could unmake
the world
and then the the changer says i and one
who could do that would not be on what
horde or narvadwen he would be here at
the gates of rock and the end of the
world would be at hand we've not come to
that pass yet so the changer and the
summoner kind of you know big powers in
roque are saying listen the stuff that
we work with it's going to remain until
the very end of the world
now that's a little bit of a presentment
because maybe it is the end of the world
and we're not recognizing it right so
that's kind of an issue
the master chanter however
says something different he says there
is something wrong
where is the king who should be in
hovnor
roque is not the heart of the world
that tower is on which the sword of
aerith aqba is said and in which the
stands the throne of sarah of amkar of
mario and 800 years has the heart of the
world been empty we have the crown but
no king to wear it we have the lost room
the king's room the rune of peace
restored to us but have we peace
let there be a king on the throne we
will have peace even in the farthest
reaches the sorcerers will practice
their arts with untroubled minds and
there will be order and a due season to
all things
now that's a little optimistic as it's
going to turn out in both this this
particular work and in the earth c
novels in general
but it's it's at least an opposed
opinion saying no there is a problem
and then
the
hand master hand says i'm with you
chanter what wonder that wizardry goes
goes astray when all else goes astray if
the whole flock wanders will our black
sheep stay by the fold the door keeper
laughs but says nothing so he's not
taking a stance so there's there's
disagreement but
in general this sentiment seems to be ah
not really a big deal we don't really
have enough information
we can't act on this news
ged the arc mage says
something different
he says so it seems then to you all it
seems there's nothing very wrong or if
there is it lies in this that our lands
are ungoverned or ill-governed so that
the arts and high skills of men suffer
from neglect with that much i agree so
he's saying some of you are saying no
problem at all some of you are saying
we've got problems of governance i i
agree with that but that's not the real
problem here
you're missing something he says
it is because the south is all but lost
to peaceful commerce that we must depend
on rumor and who has any safe word from
the west reach if ships went forth and
came back safely as of old we might know
things and so could act and i think we
would act
for my lords when the prince of enlar
tells us that he spoke the words of the
making in a spell
and did not know their meaning as when
he spoke them when the master patterner
says there's fear at the roots and will
say no more is this so little a
foundation for anxiety when a storm
begins it is only a little cloud
on the horizon
and god says
i don't know what's wrong there's a
weakening of power there's a want of
resolution
there's a dimming of the sun
i feel as if we who sit here talking
we're all wounded mortally and while we
talk and talk our blood runs softly from
our veins so he's expressing he had a
different opinion saying i think we got
to do something about this now the
question then is
all right what are we going to do
how are we going to get information and
here's where ged
as the leader of of rock takes a very
interesting stand
there's really
three main components to it he says
we gotta get more information
somebody's gotta go out there
that's gonna be me i am the warder of
roque
and i'm going to go out and find what's
what's going on
so you know some of them say ah you're
too impatient to hang out here you've
been here for five years your your feet
are getting itchy you want to go out and
do things and you say no no i i'm the
one to do it and moreover i want all of
you
the council of masters you got to stay
here
at roke and and by the way he tells the
summoner you're going to be the one to
help guard the gates you know the door
keeper guards the physical door to to
rogue but you're going to guard you know
the the wall of stones that leads to the
other world
um
it's important that the
the masters of rock remain as an
unbroken council the third thing he says
is this little guy here rn
i'm taking him with me
he's he's going to be my companion and
this is where interestingly the summoner
is like you know listen uh if you run
into some real problem what's this guy
going to do
he's not going to be particularly
helpful look at him he's he's just a
young man a nice nice looking guy you
know noble family and all that uh pledge
to you that's wonderful but don't you
need like a real mage with you and god
says no no
he he's the guy i'm taking him with me
this will be what happens
now later on in the story
we find that the enemy
or the whatever is going on
comes to rock
the summoner
after he and the the changer try to use
this
this stone
to
understand what's going on the summoner
goes off and does you might say a rogue
mission of his own and gets trapped
in the dry land the land of the dead
in the morning the changer saw at the
summoner entering his room after vain
knocking he found him stretched on the
stone floor as if he'd been hurled
backward by a heavy blow
his arms were flung wide as if in the
gesture of invocation but his hands were
cold and his open eyes saw nothing
though the changer knelt by him and
called him with a mage's authority
saying his name thrice over he lay still
he was not dead
but there was only so much life has kept
his heart beating very slowly and a
little breath
in his
lungs
so he says the enemy is reached among us
and to rock the well-defended and has
stricken our strength at his
heart
so he goes and gets the master healer
the master healer the the herbalist says
there's nothing i can actually do for
him by the way i don't know if our craft
would much avail it seems there's no
savor in my herbs of light though i say
the words of the spells there's no
virtue in him
and then
the lad says that is what the master
chanter said yesterday he stopped in the
middle of a song he was teaching us and
said i do not know what the song means
and he walked out of the room
that night the changer went from rogue
no one saw the manner of his going he
slept in a room with a window looking
out into the garden
in the morning the window was open and
he was gone they thought he'd
transformed himself with his own skill
into a bird or beast or mr wind even and
so had fled from rogue perhaps to seek
for the ark mage and here's the summary
so there were three of the masters
lost to the council of the wise as the
days passed and no news ever came of the
archmage and the summoner lay like one
dead and the changer did not return a
chill and gloom grew in the great house
this is
precisely what ged was was worried about
the master patterner steve stays in his
grove the only one who's well there's
two who are staying in good spirits the
door keeper and the master hand because
the master hand was dealing with
illusions the entire time
all the greater
powers of rock
don't seem to be working at this point
and so the crisis
actually does come to
rock and the council of the masters
you